they speak Arabic Urdu dari Pashto
Mongolian Farsi Russian who are these
people they are your loyal customers sir
they call themselves the ten rings
you're not him commander the real guy
well you said you wanted the Mandarin
you're looking right at him
as always meet us right from the start
I am the Mandarin ten rings a varial
it's well documented so you mean to tell
me then you don't know the history of
the Mandarin himself he was a warrior
King inspired generations of men to the
Middle Ages perhaps even further back in
time not the Mandarin they'll remember
is the name Trevor Slattery it's a brand
tread you're right and for that sin you
will soon suffer horribly with a hole in
your body for every ring of our faith
I'm an out-of-work actor loved you've no
idea what I'm capable of and thanks to
the CBS network I'm pretty good with a
handgun Oh
consider this a lesson on what's real
and what's not
why do people keep pointing guns at my
head
please I don't want to die I don't want
to die
target acquired an imposition extraction
unit mobilize I'm not the one that's
going to kill you mr. Slattery I'm here
to break you out that's nice
not really you see there's somebody who
wants to meet you
Donna him no you took his name and now
he wants it back
no sorry I still don't get it hi
everyone it's Charlie this is gonna be
my Ironman shang-chi Easter Egg video
there have been a lot of Mandarin
shang-chi Easter eggs in all the Iron
Man films and they tried to sort of fill
in the gaps but as you all probably saw
we're officially getting the real
Mandarin of the comics with the ten
rings the actual ten rings of power
during the Shang Chi movie so we'll
break everything down and how this all
fits into the larger Marvel Cinematic
Universe but like a lot of spider-man
films a lot of Iron Man's stuff will
inform what's going on during the Shang
Chi movie we're doing that Avengers end
game blu-ray giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your biggest shang-chi Mandarin MCU
theory on the video when we all saw the
Marvel phase for comic-con panel and
Kevin Feige officially revealed that the
title of the shang-chi movie is the
legend of the ten rings we all thought
okay Iron Man film ten rings
organization Marvel's all hail the king
one shot setting up the idea that
there's a real Mandarin in the MCU when
are we actually gonna see him are we
gonna see him during Ironman for if
they're ever gonna make that film nope
turns out we're gonna see him in the
shang-chi movie first I'll explain why I
think that is and what they're doing
with his backstory in Shang Chi's back
story from the comics but there's just
been a number of really big scenes in
Marvel films that have sort of set the
stage for the ten rings in the real
Mandarin the story of the real Mandarin
in the MCU actually starts with the
first Iron Man film if you guys went to
comic-con
the year before they premiered Iron Man
Kevin Feige was hyping up the Iron Man
film which you were going to be
releasing the next year he claimed that
the Mandarin would be the villain of
that movie but when it actually came
time to make the first Iron Man film
they cast Jeff Bridges and decided that
he was so strong that it would be a
better idea to make Obadiah Stane the
main villain of that movie so the idea
of the Mandarin was turned into the ten
rings organization the way they
explained it is there was part of a
global terror network with each cell
operating independently so this part of
the ten rings in the original Iron Man
film didn't know about any of the other
things that the ten rings was doing in
other countries or what the real
Mandarin would be doing they just sort
of operated by themselves then when we
get to Iron Man 3 you have Aldrich
Killian using aim to co-opt the real
mandarins story The Legend of the
Mandarin so to speak after the movie
came out and fans got really up
said that we didn't get the real
Mandarin Marvel sort of wrecked conned
what they had done with the character so
far with the all hail the king one shot
saying no no no don't be upset there's a
real Mandarin out there and we'll see
him someday so around that time is when
they probably started to look for ideas
for the Mandarin until they finally came
up with a shang-chi movie is the perfect
place to put him and if you didn't spot
it after that there was another ten
rings Mandarin Easter egg during the
original ant-man film when Hydra and all
those other evil organizations are vying
to try and buy the Yellow Jacket suits
one of the groups is the ten rings you
see this tattoo
so clearly the Mandarin wants to get his
hands on some of this technology just
meaning they're still operating still
very active but very much on the DL
hopefully that clears out that the
shang-chi movie will be taking place in
present day with probable flashbacks to
explain The Legend of the ten rings
because there's a couple ways that they
explain it during the all hail the king
one shot the Mandarin was a warrior king
going back to Middle Ages
maybe back even further so the story of
the shang-chi movie the legend of the
ten rings will be the legend of the
organization the ten rings the Mandarin
himself but also the legend of the real
ten rings of power the alien rings that
he wears in the comics if you're not
familiar with the shang-chi character
he's basically the best martial artists
in the world
I know Iron Fist is supposed to be the
best martial artist in the real world in
the comics Shan she is also the best
martial artist in the world but
shang-chi is Chinese his father in the
comics is foo Manchu but early theory
crafting speculation I think that
they're gonna change the backstory of
shang-chi just a little bit and when I
explained who his father is in the
comics and what that story was it'll
make a little more sense Shang cheese
father in the comics is the villain
fu-manchu's wanted to create the world's
greatest weapon now remember he's a
villain so he selects from a pool of
women that he feels like have superior
genetics eventually shang-chi is born he
trains him to be the world's best
martial artist the world's best weapon
and sets him to the task of eradicating
evil all over the world but like I said
foo Manchu is a really big villain so
eventually he sends Shane Chi to
assassinate a scientist that he claims
is evil but while Shane Chi is on his
mission one of fu-manchu's oldest
enemies intercepts him
tells him the truth about his father so
shang-chi being a hero goes about trying
to stop his father it'd be a lot like
Star Wars if Luke Skywalker had been
raised within the Empire by Darth Vader
he would have grown to be a great Dark
Jedi turned by the Emperor before he
realized what was actually going on oh
wait a minute these two are doing very
evil things I need to stop them so my
early theory about shang-chi the movie
is that in the MCU the real Mandarin
who's gonna be the main villain of the
shanky movie is going to be Shang Chi's
father instead of foo Manchu like the
comics it'll be the same basic backstory
where the Mandarin raises him to be the
world's greatest weapon assassinating
anyone that the Mandarin and the ten
rings don't like until Shang she
realizes that it's his father the
Mandarin who's the real villain in the
movie turns into a raid redemption John
wick 3style movie with Schanke trying to
evade all the mandarins henchmen while
trying to end his threat if you don't
know anything about the ten rings that
the Mandarin wears this is actually
really cool thing Fang Foom Easter Egg -
the rings were built by a race called
the macula pnes who are basically space
dragons that's the race that fing Fang
Foom the dragon belongs to so why ever
really hoping that they give us a fing
Fang Foom cameo during the movie or at
least a really big Easter Egg for the
character because we haven't seen any
huge dragons in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe yet and they haven't even done
the Midgard serpent in the Thor movies
yet he was actually going to be in
Avengers infinity war there's a deleted
scene with Thor and rocket where Thor
was going to fight the Midgard serpent
once he had gotten Stormbreaker but they
decided to go in a completely different
direction with the battle in Wakanda so
the only thing that they haven't really
explained though is is that if the
Mandarin is the same Mandarin this whole
time he's very very long-lived or
functionally immortal like the
Asgardians or the Eternals or if it's a
hereditary title that just passed down
like is the Mandarin shank Chi's father
who took the title after his father died
and then took the ten rings with that or
is it a situation where they'll find the
actual ten rings during the movie but I
think part of the idea is is that the
Mandarin wouldn't have named his
organization the ten rings if he didn't
actually have the ten rings with him
these are the names of the ten rings and
these are what they do they all have
very different powers so there's the
remake er influence spin spectral night
bringer
demonic incandescence lightning zero in
the liar these won't be quite as
powerful as the Infinity stones but
they'll still be very very powerful the
remake er can rearrange matter influence
gives off concussive blasts the spin
ring is more like a vortex beam spectral
is more of a disintegration type of beam
night bringer allows the Mandarin to
wield the dark force demonic just allows
him to wield the electromagnetic
spectrum like magneto would incandescent
gives him fire based powers the lyre
gives him psychic powers lightning gives
him electric blasts and the zero ring
gives him ice based powers so he
basically controls most of the elements
a lot of psychic abilities in a lot of
magical abilities like wielding the dark
force so it'll be really exciting to see
what kind of spin the movie puts on that
but you guys can post all your theories
in the comments how you think the movie
is going to handle the actual physical
ten rings
the whole idea of the shame cheat
character though is that he'll be around
in present day to join the next version
of The Avengers anyone besides Black
Widow that gets at Marvel phase four in
Marvel phase five film is pluggin it
wind up in that next Avengers film Black
Widow just being the exception because
she's dead in present-day and her movies
gonna be a prequel as you've all
probably seen most of what we know about
Schanke and the Mandarin in the ten
rings have come through the Iron Man
films so don't be surprised if there's a
lot of stark tech Easter eggs and Iron
Man's stuff going on in the shang-chi
movie just like we see it all the
spider-man movies there's a bunch more
Marvel phase four videos that I'm
working on they're dropping endgame on
blu-ray this week so they'll be much
more deleted scenes and bonus features
I'll do videos for that stuff too while
you wait for everything click here for
the Deadpool 3 teaser that Ryan Reynolds
just dropped and click here for my last
big Avengers endgame deleted scenes
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]